in tech industry terms you know if the
last decade was about digitizing
healthcare the next decade is about
making all that digital data good for
something and that good for something is
going to depend on data flowing where it
needs to flow at the right time you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using over the
past decade the healthcare industry has
undergone a series of technological
changes in an effort to modernize it and
bring it into the digital world but the
call for innovation persists one person
answering that call is dr. Peter Lee
corporate vice president of Microsoft
healthcare a new organization dedicated
to accelerating healthcare innovation
through AI and cloud computing today dr.
Lee talks about how Ms R's advances in
healthcare technology are impacting the
business of Microsoft healthcare he also
explains how promising innovations like
precision medicine conversational
chatbots
& Asher's API for data interoperability
may make healthcare better and more
efficient in the future that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
Peter Lee welcome to the podcast
thank you it's great to be here so
you're a Microsoft corporate vice
president and head of a relatively new
organization here called Microsoft
healthcare
let's start by situating that within the
larger scope of Microsoft Research and
Microsoft were at large
what is Microsoft healthcare why was it
formed and what do you hope to do with
it it's such a great question because
when we were first asked to take this on
it was confusing to me healthcare is
such a gigantic business and Microsoft
you know the number that really gets me
is Microsoft has commercial contracts
with almost a hundred and sixty nine
thousand healthcare organizations around
the world it's just massive basically
anything from a one nurse clinic in
Nairobi Kenya to Kaiser Permanente or
United Healthcare and everything in
between and so it was confusing to try
to understand what is such an adult of
thinking to ask a researchy organization
to take this on but you know the future
of healthcare is so vibrant and dynamic
right now and is so dependent on AI on
cloud computing big data I think he was
really wanting us to think about that
future
let's situate you okay you cross a lot
of boundaries from pure to Applied
Research computer science to medicine
you've been head of Carnegie Mellon
University's computer science department
but you are also an office director at
DARPA which is the poster child for
Applied Research you're an ACM Fellow
and on the board of directors of the
Allen Institute for AI but you're also a
member of the National Academy of
Medicine fairly newly minted as I
understand right just this year and on
the board of Kaiser Permanente's School
of Medicine so I'd ask you what gets you
up in the morning but it seems like you
never go to bed so instead describe what
you do for a living Peter how you choose
what hat to wear in the morning and
what's a typical day in your life look
like well you know this was never my
plan I I just loved research and
thinking hard about problems being
around other smart people and thinking
hard about problems getting real depth
of understanding that's what gets me up
but
think the world today what's so exciting
about it for anyone with the research
gene is that research in a variety of
areas has become so important to
practical everyday life it's become
important to microsoft's business not
just Microsoft but all of our
competitors and so I just feel like I'm
in a lucky position as well as a lot of
my colleagues I don't think any of us
started with that idea we just wanted to
do research and now we're finding
ourselves sort of in the middle of
things
right well talk a little bit more about
computer science and medicine how have
you moved from one to the other and how
do you kind of envision yourself in this
arena
well my joke here is these were changes
that actually Satya Nadella forced me
and it's a little bit of a joke because
I was actually honored that he would
think of me this way but it was also
painful because I was in a comfort zone
just doing my own research leading
research teams and then you know such
until it becomes the CEO Harry Shum
comes on board to drive innovation and i
get asked to think about new ways to
take research ideas and get them out
into the world and then three years
after that i get asked to think about
the same thing for healthcare and each
one of those to my mind are examples of
this concept that such it likes to talk
about growth mindset I joke that growth
mindset is actually a euphemism because
each time you have to make these changes
you just get this feeling of dread you
might have a minute where you're feeling
honored that someone would ask you
something but then and boy I was you
know on a roll in what I was doing
before and you do spend some time
feeling sorry for yourself but when you
work through those moments you find that
you do have those periods in your life
where you grow a lot and my immersion
with so many great people in healthcare
over the last three or four years has
been one of those big growth periods
and do we recognize then let's say by
the National Academies is sort of
validation of that
alright so rewind just a little bit and
talk about that space you were in just
before you got into the healthcare
situation you were doing Microsoft
Research we're on the spectrum from pure
like your Carnegie Mellon roots to
applied like your DARPA roots did that
land there's an organization called NExT
here I think right you know when I was
in academia academia really knows how to
do research
yeah and they really put the creative
the graduate students and the faculty at
the top of the pyramid socially in the
university it's just a great set up and
it's organized into departments which
are each named after a research area or
a discipline in within the departments
are groups of people organized by
sub-discipline in their area and so it's
an organizing principle that's tried and
true when I went to DARPA it was
completely different the departments
aren't organized by research area
they're organized by mission some easily
accessable goal or objective you can
always answer the question have we
accomplished it yet or not and so
research at DARPA is organized around
those missions and that was a big
learning experience for me it's not like
saying we're going to do computer vision
research we'll be doing that for the
next 50 years it's can we eliminate the
language barrier for all internet
connected people that's a mission you
can answer the question you know how
close are we right and so the mix
between those two modes of research from
academia to DARPA is something that I
took with me when I joined Microsoft
research and you know Microsoft Research
has some mix but I thought the balance
could be slowly different and then when
Satya Nadella became the CEO and Harry
Shum took over our division they
challenged me to go bigger on that idea
and that's how NExT started. NExT tried
to organize itself by missions and it
tried to take passionate people and
brilliant ideas and grow them into new
lines of business new engineering
capable
for Microsoft and along the way create
new CVPs and TFS for our company there's
a tension here because one of the things
that's so important for great research
is stability and so when you organize
things like you do in academia and in
large parts of Microsoft research you
get that stability by having groups of
people devoted to an area we have for
example say computer networking research
groups that are best in the world and
they've been stable for a long time and
you know they just create more and more
knowledge and depth and that stability
is it's just so important you feel like
you can take big risks when you have
that stability when you are a mission
oriented, like in NExT, these missions are
coming and going all the time so that
has to be managed carefully but the
other benefit of that management wise is
more people get a chance to step up and
express their leadership so it's not
that either model is superior to the
other but it's good to have both and
when you're in a company with all of the
resources that Microsoft has we really
should have both well let's zoom out and
talk somewhat generally about the
promise of AI because that's where we're
gonna land on some of the more specific
things we'll talk about in a bit but
Microsoft has several initiatives under
a larger umbrella called AI for good and
the aim is to bring the power of AI to
societal scale problems in things like
agriculture broadband accessibility
education environment and of course
medicine so AI for health is one of
these initiatives but it's not the same
thing as Microsoft healthcare well the
whole AI for good program is so exciting
and I'm just so proud to be in a company
that makes this kind of commitment you
can think of it as a philanthropic
grants program and it is in fact in all
of these areas providing funding and
technical support to really worthy teams
passionate people really trying to bring
AI to bear for the greater good but it's
also the case that we devote our own
research resources to these things so
it's not just giving out grants but it's
actually getting into club
relations what's interesting about AI
for health is that it's the first pillar
in the air for good program that
actually overlaps with a business at
Microsoft and that's Microsoft
Healthcare one weight I think about it
is it's an outlet for researchers to
think about what could a I do to advance
medicine when you talk to a lot of
researchers in computer science
departments or across Microsoft research
labs increasingly you see more and more
of them getting interested in healthcare
in medicine and the first things that
they tend to think about if they're new
to the field are diagnostic and
therapeutic applications can we come up
with something that will detect ovarian
cancer earlier can we come up with new
imaging techniques that will help
radiologists do a better job those sorts
of diagnostic therapeutic applications I
think are incredibly important for the
world but they are not Microsoft
businesses so the AI for health program
can provide an outlet for those types of
research passions and then there are
also as a secondary element four billion
people on this planet today that have no
reasonable access to health care AI and
technology have to be part of the
solution to creating that more equitable
access and so that's another element
that again doesn't directly touch
Microsoft's business today in Microsoft
healthcare but is so important we have a
lot to offer so AI for health is just I
think incredibly visionary and wonderful
program for that
well let's zoom back out No let's zoom
back in I've lost track of the camera I
don't know where it is let's talk about
the idea of precision medicine or
precision healthcare and the dream of
improving those diagnostic and
therapeutic interventions with AI tell
us what precision medicine is and how
that plays out and how are the two
rather culturally diverse fields of
computer science and medicine coming
together to solve for X here yeah I
think one of the things that is
sometimes underappreciated is over the
past 10 to 20 years there's been a
massive digitization of health care in
medicine after the 2008 economic
collapse in 2009 there was the ARRA
there was a piece of legislation
attached to that called the high tech
act and high tech actually required
healthcare organizations to digitize
health records and so for the past 10
years we've gone from something like 15%
of health records being in digital form
to today now over 98% of health records
are in digital form and along with that
medical devices that measure you have
gone digital
our ability to sequence and analyze your
genome your proteome have gone digital
and now the question is what can we do
with all the digital information and on
top of that we have social information
yeah people are carrying mobile devices
people talk to computers at home people
go to their Walgreens to get their flu
shots and all of this is in digital form
and so the question is can we take all
of that digital data and use it to
provide highly personalized and
precisely targeted diagnostics and
therapeutics to people can we get a
holistic kind of 360-degree view of you
specifically of what's going on with you
right now
and what might go on over the next
several years and target your wellness
can we advance from sick care which is
really what we have today to healthcare
when a big tech company like Microsoft
throws its hat in the healthcare ring
and publicly says that it has the goal
of transforming how healthcare is
experienced and delivered I immediately
think of the word disruption but you've
said healthcare isn't something you
disrupt what do you mean by that
and if disruption isn't the goal what is
right you know healthcare is not a
normal business worldwide it's actually
a seven point five trillion dollar
business and for Microsoft it's
incredibly important because as we were
discussing it's gone digital and
increasingly that digital data and the
services and AI and computation to make
good use of a data is moving to the
cloud so it has to be something that we
very close attention to and we have a
business priority to support that but
you know it's not a normal business in
many many different senses as a patient
people don't shop at least not on price
for their health care they might go on a
website to look at ratings of primary
care physicians but certainly if you're
in a car accident you're unconscious
you're not shopping you're just looking
for the best possible care and similarly
there is a massive shift for healthcare
providers away from what's called
fee-for-service and towards something
called value-based care where doctors
and clinics are being reimbursed based
on the quality of the outcomes what
you're trying to do is create success
for those people and organizations that
let's face it they've devoted their
lives to helping people be healthier and
so it really is almost the purest
expression of Microsoft's mission of
empowerment it's not how do we create a
disruption that allows us to make more
money but instead you know how do we
empower people in organizations to
deliver better and receive better
healthcare today in the u.s. a primary
care doctor spends almost twice as much
time entering clinical documentation as
they do actually taking care of patients
some of the doctors we work with here at
Microsoft call this pajama time because
you spend your day working with patients
and then at home when you crawled to bed
you have to finish up your documentation
that's a big source of burnout oh yeah
and so what can we do using speech
recognition technologies natural
language processing DIYer ization to
enable that clinical note-taking to be
dramatically reduced you know how would
that help doctors pay more attention to
their patients there is something called
revenue cycle management and it's sort
of sometimes viewed as a kind of evil
way to maximize revenues in a clinic or
hospital system but it is also a place
where you can really try to eliminate
waste today in the US market most
estimates say that about a trillion
dollars every year is just gone to waste
in the US
care system and so these are sort of
data analysis problems in this highly
complex system that really require the
kind of AI and machine learning that we
develop and those are the kinds of
disruptions we'd like to see that's
right yeah well all them successes as
you did well and there are disruptions
though other disruptions that help
today's working doctors and nurses they
help today's hospital administrators
let's talk about several innovations
that you've actually made to help
support the healthcare industries
transformation last year a year ago at
the hims conference you talked about
tools that would improve communication
the healthcare experience and
interoperability and data sharing in the
cloud tell us about these innovations
what did you envision then and now a
year later how are they working out yeah
maybe the one I'd like to start with is
about interoperability I sometimes have
a joke that it's the least sexy topic
but it's the one that is I think the
most important to us in tech industry
terms you know if the last decade was
about digitizing healthcare the next
decade is about making a Ledge digital
data good for something and that good
for something is going to depend on data
flowing where it needs to flow at the
right time and doing that in a way that
protects people's privacy because health
data is very very personal and so a
fundamental issue there is
interoperability today while we have all
this digital data it's really locked
into thousands of different incompatible
data formats it doesn't get exposed
through modern api's or microservices
it's oftentimes siloed for business
reasons and so unlocking that is
important one way that we look at it
here at Microsoft is we are seeing a
rising tidal wave of healthcare
organizations starting to move to the
cloud probably 10 years from now almost
all healthcare
we'll be in the cloud and so with that
historic shift that will happen only
once ever in human history what can we
do today to ensure that we end up in a
better place ten years now than we are
now in interoperability is one of the
keys there and that's something that's
been recognized by multiple governments
the US government through the Centers
for Medicare and Medicaid Services has
proposed new regulations that required
the use of specific interoperable data
standards and API frameworks and I'm
very proud that Microsoft has
participated in helping endorse and
guide the specific technical choices in
those new rules so what is the API that
Microsoft has so the data standard that
we've put a lot of effort behind there's
something called fire fhir fast
healthcare interoperability resources
and for anyone that's used to working in
the web you can look at fire and you'll
see something very familiar it's a
modern data standard it's extensible
because medical science is advancing all
the time and it's highly susceptible to
analysis through machine learning and so
it's utterly modern and standardized and
I think fire can be a lingua franca for
all healthcare data everywhere and so
for Microsoft we've integrated fire as a
first class data type in our cloud in
Azure
we've enabled fire in office so the
team's application for example can
connect to health data for doctors and
nurses and there's integration going on
into dynamics and so it's a way to
convert everything that we do here
Microsoft into great healthcare capable
tools and once you have fire in the
cloud then you also suddenly unlock all
the AI tools that we have to just enable
all of that precision medicine down the
line it's such a biblical reference
right then the cloud in the fire you
know there's an endless supply of bad
puns or on fire and say oh thank you for
contributing today well it makes you
think about the fire festival which was
spelled FY re which is the biggest
debacle in festival history I should say
by the way another thing that everyone
as Microsoft should be proud of is we
have really been one of the chief
architects for this new future one of
the most important people and the fire
development community is Josh Mandel who
works with us here at Microsoft
healthcare and he has the title chief
architect but it's not chief architect
for Microsoft it's chief architect for
the cloud oh my so he spends time
talking to the folks at Google
AWS at Salesforce and so on because
we're trying to bring the entire cloud
ecosystem along to this new future tell
me a little bit about what role BOTS
might play in this arena bots are really
interesting because how many listeners
have received a lab test result and have
no idea what it means
how many people have received some weird
piece of paper or bill in the mail from
their insurance company it's not just
medical advice you know where you have a
scratch in your throat and you were
worried about what what you should do
now that's important too but the idea of
bots in health care really span all
these other things one of the most
touching in a project led by Hadassah
patron and her team has been in the area
of clinical trials so there is a website
called clinical trials.gov and it
contains a registry describing every
registered clinical trial going on so
now if you are desperate for more
experimental care or your doctor
treating someone and you're desperate
for this you know how do you find out of
thousands of documents and they're
complicated right technical measures
things yeah and it's difficult if you go
to clinical trials.gov and type into the
search box breast cancer you get
hundreds of results so the cool project
that had us and her team lead was to use
machine reading from Microsoft Research
out of Haiphong Poon's team to read all
of those clinical trials documents and
create a knowledge graph and use that
knowledge graph than to drive a
conversational chat bot so that you can
engage in a conversation so you can say
you know I have breast cancer I'm
looking for a clinical trial and the
chat bot will start to ask you questions
in order to
eventually to the one or two or three
clinical trials that might be just right
for you and so this is something that we
just think has a lot of potential yeah
and business-wise there are more mundane
but also important things just call
centers boy those nurses are busy mmm
what would happen if we had a bot that
would triage and tee up some of those
things and really give superpowers to
those call center nurses and so it's
that type of thing that I think is very
exciting about conversational tech in
general and of course Microsoft Research
and NExT should be really proud of
really pioneering a lot of this mod
technology so if I employed a bot to
narrow down the clinical trials could I
get myself into one is that what you're
explaining here yeah in fact the idea
here is that this would help
tremendously
the connection between prospective
patients and clinical trials it's so
important because pharmaceutical
companies and clinics that are sitting
up clinical trials more than 50% of them
fail to recruit enough participants they
just never get off the ground because
they don't get enough the recruitment
problem is so difficult Wow and so this
is something that can really help on
both ends I didn't even think about it
from the other angle like getting people
in I always just assumed well a clinical
trial no biggie
it's such a sad thing that most clinical
trials fail and fail because of the
recruitment problem huh well let's talk
a little bit more about some of the
really interesting projects that are
going on across the labs here at
Microsoft Research so what are some of
the projects and who are some of the
people that are working to improve
healthcare in technology research yeah I
think pretty much every MSR lab is doing
interesting things there's some
wonderful work going on in the Cambridge
UK lab in Chris bishops lab they're in a
group being led by a dictionary one of
the things there has been a set of
projects in collaboration with Novartis
really looking at new ideas about a
our molecule design for cellular
therapies as well as very precise dosing
of therapies for things like macular
degeneration and so these are sort of
bringing the very best machine learning
and AI researchers shoulder-to-shoulder
with the best researchers and scientists
at Novartis to really kind of innovate
and invent the future in the MSR India
lab serum Raja Monty's team they've been
standing up really impressive set of
technologies and projects that have to
do with global access to healthcare and
this is something that I think is just
incredibly incredibly important you know
we really could enable through more
intelligent medical devices for example
much less well trained technicians and
clinicians to be able to deliver
healthcare at a distance the other thing
that is very exciting to me there is
just looking at data you know how do we
normalize data from lots of different
sources and then MSR Asia and Beijing
they've increasingly been redirecting
some of the amazing advances that lab is
famous for in computer vision to the
medical imaging space and they're just
amazing possibilities in taking images
that might not be high-resolution enough
for precise diagnosis and using AI to
kind of magically improve the resolution
and so just the cross board is you go
from kind of lab to lab you just see
some really inspiring
work going on yeah some of the
researchers have been on the podcast
antonio crimini see within ER I haven't
had a Ethan Jackson from premonition ya
know the premonition well internet
community and the work that he led an
inner eye you know we actually went all
the way to an fda 510 K approval on the
tumor segmentations and the components
of that now are going into our cloud
really amazing stuff yeah and then
premonition this is one of these things
that is in the age of coronavirus the
thing that is so important is we talked
of precision medicine before but there
is also an emerging
of precision population health and in
fact the National Academy of Medicine
just recently codified that as an
official part of medical research and
it's bringing some of the same sort of
precision medicine ideas but to
population health applications and
studies and so when you look at
premonition and the ability to look at a
whole community and get a genetically
precise diagnosis of what is going on in
that community it is something that
could really be a game-changer
especially in an era where we are seeing
more challenging infectious disease
outbreaks I think a lot of people would
say can we speed that one up a little I
want you to talk for a minute about the
broader tech in healthcare ecosystem and
what it takes to be a leader both
thought and otherwise in the field so
you've noted that we're in the middle of
a big transformation that's only gonna
happen once in history and because of
that you have a question that you asked
yourself and everyone who reports to you
so what's the question that you ask and
how does the answer impact Microsoft's
position as a leader right you know
healthcare in most parts of the world is
really facing some big challenges it's
at a financial breaking point and almost
all developed countries the spread of
the latest access to good medical
practice has been slowing in the
developing world and as you kind of look
at how to break out of these cycles
increasingly people turn to technology
and the kind of shining beacon of hope
is this mountain of digital data that's
being produced every single day and so
how can we convert that into what's
called the Triple Aim of better outcomes
lower costs and better experiences so
then when you come to Microsoft you have
to wonder well if we're going to try to
make a contribution how do you do it
when such an Adele has to stick this on
we told ourselves a joke that he was
throwing us into the middle of the
Pacific Ocean and asking us to find land
and because there's just such a big
complex space where do you go and we had
more jokes about this because you start
swinging for a while and you start
meeting lots of other people who are
just as lost and you actually feel a
little shame to feel good about seeing
other people drowning but it
fundamentally doesn't help you figure
out what to work on and so we started to
ask ourselves the question if Microsoft
were to disappear today in what ways
with health care be harmed or held back
tomorrow and into the future if our
hyperscale cloud words disappear today
in what ways would that matter to
healthcare if all of the AI capabilities
that we can deploy so cheaply on that
cloud were to despair how would that
matter and then since we're coming out
of Microsoft Research if Microsoft
Research were to disappear today in what
ways would that matter and asking
ourselves that question has sort of
helped us focus on the areas where we
think we have a right to play and I
think the wonderful thing about
Microsoft today is we have a business
model that makes it easy to align those
things to our business priorities and so
it's really a special time right now
well this is not to change tone really
quickly but this is the part of the
podcast where I asked what could
possibly go wrong and since we've
actually just used a drowning in the sea
metaphor it's probably apropos but when
you bring nascent AI technologies and I
say nascent because most people have
said even though it's been going on for
a long time we're still in an infancy
phase of these technologies when you
bring that to health care and you're
literally dealing with life-and-death
consequences there's not any margin for
error
so I realized sit the answer to this
question be too long for the podcast but
I have to ask what keeps you up at night
and how are you and your colleagues
addressing potential negative
consequences at the outset rather than
waiting for the problems to appear
downstream that's such an important
question and it actually has multiple
answers maybe the one that I think would
be most obvious to the listeners of this
podcast
have to do with patient safety medical
practice and medical science has really
advanced on the idea of prospective
studies and clinical validation but
that's not how computer science broadly
speaking works in fact when we talk
about machine learning it's really based
on retrospective studies you know we
take data that was generated in the past
and we tried to extract a model through
a machine learning from it and what the
world has learned in the last few years
is that those retrospective studies
don't necessarily hold up very well
prospectively and so that gap is very
dangerous it can lead to new therapies
and diagnosis that go wrong in
unpredictable ways and there is sort of
an over exuberance on both sides as
technologists we're pretty confident
about what we do and we see lots of
problems that we can solve and the
healthcare community is sometimes
dazzled by all of the magical machine
learning we do and so there can be
overconfidence on both sides that's one
thing that I worry about a lot because
you know all over our field not just all
over Microsoft but it costs all the
other major tech companies and
universities there are just great
technologists that are doing some
wonderful things and are
well intentioned but aren't necessarily
validated in the right way and so that's
something that really is worrisome going
along with safety is privacy of people's
health data and while I think most
people would be glad to donate their
health data for scientific progress no
one wants to be exploited exploited for
money or worse you know denied for
example insurance and you know these two
things can really lead to outcomes over
the next decade that could really damage
our ability to make good progress in the
future so that said we're pretty good at
identifying the problem we may be able
to start a good conversation air quotes
on that but this is for me like what are
you doing yes this is a huge thing and I
really think for real progress and real
transformation that the foundation says
be right and those foundations do start
with this idea of interoperability so
the good thing is that major governments
including the US government are seeing
this and they're making very definitive
moves to foster this interoperable
future and so now our role in that is to
provide the technical guidance and the
technologies so that that's done in the
right way and so everything that we at
Microsoft are doing around the
interoperability around security around
Identity Management differential privacy
all of the work that came out of
Microsoft research and confidential
computing all of those things are likely
to be part of this future as important
as confidential computing has been as a
product of Microsoft research it's going
to be way way more important in this
healthcare future and so it's really up
to us to make sure that regulators and
lawmakers and clinicians are aware and
smart about these things and we can
provide that technical guidance what
about the other companies that you
mentioned I mean you're not in this
alone and it's not just companies its
Nations and I daresay rogue actors that
are skilled in this arena how do you get
sort of agreement and compliance I would
say that Microsoft is in a good position
because it has a clear business model if
someone is asking us well what you can
do with our data we have a very clear
business model that says that we don't
monetize on your data but everyone's
going to have to figure that out also
when you are getting into a new area
like healthcare every tech company is a
big complicated place with lots of
stakeholders lots of competing internal
interests lots of politics and so
Microsoft I think is in a very good
position that way to we're all operating
as one Microsoft but it's so important
that we all find ways to work together
one point of contact has been engineered
by the White House and something called
the blue button Developers Conference so
that's where I am literally holding
hands with my counterparts at Google at
Salesforce at Amazon at IBM and making
certain pledges there and so the
convening power of governments is pretty
powerful it's story time
we've talked a little bit about your
academic and professional life give us a
short personal history where did it all
start for Peter Lee and how did he end
up where he is today well let's see so
I'm Korean by heritage I was born in
Ohio but Korean by heritage and my
parents immigrated from Korea my dad was
a physics professor
he's long retired now and my mother a
chemistry professor Wow and she passed
away some years ago but I guess as a an
Asian kid growing up in a physical
science household I was destined to
become a scientist myself and in fact
they never said it out loud but I think
it was a disappointment to them when I
went to college to study math and then
maybe even the bigger disappointment
when I went from math to computer
science in grad school of course they're
very proud of me now where'd you go to
school I went to the University of
Michigan I was there as an undergrad and
then I was planning to go work after
that I actually interviewed at a little
tiny company in the Pacific Northwest
called Microsoft
and but I was wooed by my senior
research advisor at Michigan to stay on
for my PhD and so I stayed and then went
from grad school right to Carnegie
Mellon University as a professor and
then worked your way up to leading the
department yes I was there for 24 years
there were wonderful years a Carnegie
Mellon University is just a wonderful
wonderful place and I was like there's a
pipeline from Microsoft Research I
remember as an assistant professor when
Rick Ratched came to my office to tell
me that he was leaving to start this
thing called Microsoft Research and I
was really sad and shocked by that now
Here I am well tell us if you can one
interesting thing about you that people
might not know I don't know if people
know this or not but I have always had a
interest in cars and fast cars I spent
some time when I was young
racing in something called shifter carts
and then later in open-wheel Formula
Ford and then when I got my first real
job at Carnegie Mellon and I had enough
money that I spent quite a bit of it
trying to get a sponsored ride with a
semi-pro team I never managed to make it
it's hard just kind of split being an
assistant professor and trying to follow
that passion you know I don't do that
too much anymore once you are married
and have a child the annoyance factor
gets a little high but it's something
that I still really love and there's a
community of people of course I place
like Microsoft it's really passionate
about cars as well as we close Peter I'd
like you to leave our listeners with
some parting advice
many of them are computer science people
who may want to apply their skills in
the world of health care but are not
sure how to get there from here we're in
the vast sea of Technology and
healthcare research possibilities should
emerging researchers set their sights
and where should they begin their swim
you know I think it's all about data and
how to make something good out of data
and today especially you know we are in
that big sea of data
every one of them has different formats
different rules most of them don't have
modern api's and so things that can help
evolve that system to a true
ocean of data I think anything to that
extent will be great and it is not just
tinkering around with interfaces it's
actually a I to say normalize the
schemas of two different datasets
intelligently is something that we will
need to do using the kind of latest
machine learning latest program
synthesis the kind of latest data
science techniques that we have on offer
who do you want on your team in the
coming years the thing that I think I
find so exciting about great researchers
today is their intellectual flexibility
to start looking at idea in getting more
and more depth of understanding but then
evolved as a person to understanding you
know what is the value of this in the
world and understanding that that is a
competitive world and so how willing are
you to compete in that competitive
marketplace to make the best stuff and
that evolution that we are seeing over
and over again with people out of
Microsoft research it's just incredibly
exciting when you see someone like a
Gailen hunt or a Doug Berger or Lily
Chang come out of Microsoft research and
then evolve into these world leaders in
their respective fields not just in
research but spanning research to really
competing in a highly competitive
marketplace dad is the future Pete
Earley thank you for joining us on the
podcast today it's been an absolute
delight thank you for having me it's
been fun
to learn more about dr. Peter Lee and
how Microsoft is working to empower
healthcare professionals around the
world visit microsoft.com/testlabguides